let's have a look
at the pushdrab api just before
recording this video
i fine-tuned a bot model on the glue
arma pc
we won't go over the fine tuning code
here because you can find it in any
transformers tutorial
or by looking at the videos linked below
what
interests us here is what happens once
training is finished
and we've got metrics we're happy about
this video requires you to have your
authentication token stored
which can be easily done by typing aging
face
cli locally in a terminal or like this
in the notebook by using an exclamation
mark
with that done the push to have api
allows us to upload to the
input sub or model its configuration and
the associated tokenizer
we just have to specify a repository
name and all those objects
are going to be uploaded to mynamespace
in this repository
we can also upload to a specific
organization
by using the organization argument
once it's done this command returns the
url of a commit we can go and inspect
just before checking this note that if
you aren't using trainer
you can use the push tool method
directly onto your model
or your tokenizer by passing the commit
url into my browser
i can access my repository called
functionbird as expected and i see
that several files have been added a
model card
the model configuration the model
weights
as well as all the files required by the
tokenizer
the trainer drafted a model card for us
which contained the final evaluation
results
the ipr parameters used for training
the table of intermediate evaluation
results as well
as the framework versions we were using
now that this model is on the hub we can
use it from anywhere
with the from pre-trained method we just
have to use the enterprise for the verb
and we can see that the model
configurations on weights
are automatically downloaded we can use
this model as we would any other
transformers model
for instance by loading in in a pipeline
since the mrpc dataset is a dataset of
pairs of sentences
where the task is to determine if two
sentences are processes of one another
or not
we use it on two sentences separated by
the step token
it's a little bit disappointing to see
that it's predicting label 0
which doesn't make any sense that's
because i didn't specify any label when
i created the model configuration
fixing this is super easy with the push
tool api
first we can fix the configuration
by setting the label to id and id2 label
fields to the proper values
then we can push the new configuration
inside a repository this command takes a
bit of time because it actually clones
the repo
puts the new config inside and then
commits and push to
the fine shield belt repository once
this is done
we can create a new pipeline and see
that the new configuration file is
downloaded automatically
thanks to the built-in versioning system
and we get the proper label
we can also play directly with this
model
onto the model card using the inference
widget
note that the first time you use it it
can take a bit of time to load the model
which i'm going to cut from this video
once the model is loaded
we can double check we get the same
results as before on the widget
try the push to api on your models today